.
WE HAVE A FOX REPORTER INSIDE
THE EVENT.
WE'LL TELL YOU WHAT HE SAID
STRAIGHT AHEAD.
FIRST, NEW EVIDENCE TONIGHT THAT
WE, YOU COME IN THE AMERICAN
PEOPLE, ALL OF US, WE WERE ALL
LIED TO.
WE WERE LIED TO BY THE MOB AND
THE MEDIA, LIED TO BY BIG TECH,
LIED TO REPEATEDLY BY THE
DEMOCRATIC PARTY.
LIED TO BY JOE BIDEN AND THE
BIDEN FAMILY, LIED TO BY THE
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT, AND ALL OF
IT WAS AN EFFORT TO ELECT
JOE BIDEN AND DEFEAT
DONALD TRUMP.
IN FACT, HIS LAPTOP FROM HELL
WAS VERY REAL AND FROM THE
NEW YORK POST ABOUT THAT LAPTOP,
IT WAS ACCURATE AND IT WAS TRUE.
HUNTER'S FATHER, THE BIG GUY
ACCORDING TO THE EMAILS IN THAT
LAPTOP IS IMPLEMENTED IN HIS SON
THE PASTOR'S SHADY INTERNATIONAL
BUSINESS DEALS AND NOW
"THE WASHINGTON POST,"
"THE NEW YORK TIMES," ALL OF A
SUDDEN VERIFIED THIS
INFORMATION.
THERE IS NO MYSTERY HERE.
THIS IS A MAY
MAJOR MASSIVE CYA.HE COULD SOONS
CRIMINAL CHARGES SAYING THAT, WE
MIGHT GET CAUGHT COVERING UP FOR
THE BIDENS AGAIN.
WE'VE GOT TO ACT LIKE WE
REPORTED ON THIS STORY.
IT WON'T WORK.
WE WILL TAKE A TRIP DOWN MEMORY
LANE, REVIEW THE BIGGEST LIES
FROM AMERICA'S TRUSTED
INSTITUTIONS.
BUT FIRST, LET'S TAKE A MOMENT
TO RECAP WHAT THEY ARE LYING
ABOUT.
WE BEGIN WITH A LITTLE
BACKGROUND ON JOE BIDEN'S ADULT
SON HUNTER BIDEN.
DEEPLY TROUBLED MAN, HE'S
STRUGGLED WITH A SEVERE AND
OFTEN DEBILITATING ADDICTION TO
CRACK COCAINE AND PROSTITUTES.
HIS RESUME AND BACKGROUND ARE
ANYTHING BUT PRISTINE.
FOR YEARS, ZERO EXPERIENCE
HUNTER AND HIS SHADY BUSINESS
OPPOSED ASSOCIATES GARNERED
LUCRATIVE PAYOUTS FROM FOREIGN
NATIONAL ALL OVER THE WORLD.
FOR EXAMPLE, RECEIVED A WHOPPING
$3.5 MILLION WIRE TRANSFER FROM
THE RUSSIAN OLIGARCH, HE ALSO
GOT $5 MILLION FROM A STATE
BACKED CHINESE COMPANY, PART OF
A MULTIBILLION-DOLLAR DEAL TO
THE BANK OF CHINA.
ANOTHER $100,000 PLUS FOR
INTERNATIONAL SHOPPING SPREE.
WHY DOESN'T THAT HAPPEN TO ANY
OF YOU?
ON TOP OF THE $1.5 BILLION DEAL
WITH THE BANK OF CHINA, THAT'S A
LOT OF MONEY.
PLUS ANOTHER 100 GRAND PLUS FROM
THE KAZAKHSTAN OLIGARCH
EARMARKED FOR A BRAND-NEW SPORTS
CAR.
WHAT A LIFE HE HAS.
LET'S NOT FORGET THE 1.5 MILLION
HE RECEIVED SITTING ON THE BOARD
OF BURISMA HOLDINGS, A MASSIVE
OIL AND GAS CONGLOMERATE.
HUNTER HAD ZERO EXPERIENCE IN
ENERGY, OIL, GAS, AND NO
EXPERIENCE WITH UKRAINE.
ZERO EXPERIENCE WITH INVESTING
ABROAD ALSO.
STILL THESE SHADY FOREIGN
NATIONALS, CHINA, EASTERN EUROPE
UKRAINE, MAKING THE HUNTER BIDEN
FAMILIES AND TO GET EXTREMELY
RICH.
IT'S ALL THE TIP OF THE ICEBERG.
STOP FOR ONE SECOND, PAUSE AND
ASK YOURSELF WHAT IF HUNTER'S
NAME WAS TRUMP?
WHY WERE THESE WEALTHY
FOREIGNERS SENDING A PROSTITUTE
LOVING CRACKHEAD, HIS DAD WAS A
PROMINENT SENATOR TURNED
VICE PRESIDENT.
A LOT OF THIS HAPPENED WHEN JOE
WAS VICE PRESIDENT AND THE WORLD
KNEW THAT JOE HAD PRESIDENTIAL
ASPIRATIONS.
THEY WERE PAYING FOR ACCESS TO
THE HIGHEST LEVELS OF OUR
GOVERNMENT AND IT APPEARS THEY
GOT IT.
HUNTER ADMITTED THIS IN AN
INTERVIEW WITH GMA, UNMITIGATED
DISASTER.
LET'S NOT FORGET AS
VICE PRESIDENT BIDEN WITHHELD
THE BILLION TAXPAYER DOLLARS IN
LOAN GUARANTEES FROM UKRAINE,
YOU AREN'T GETTING THE BILLION
UNTIL YOU FIRE THE PROSECUTOR.
THINK ABOUT THIS.
VICE PRESIDENT OF OUR COUNTRY
SAYING FIRE A PROSECUTOR OR YOU
ARE NOT GETTING THE MONEY AND
YOU HAVE SIX HOURS AND COME UP
SON OF A B, THEY DID IT.
TURNED OUT THE PROSECUTOR WAS
INVESTIGATING ZERO EXPERIENCE
HUNTER AND THE COMPANY HE WAS IN
BUSINESS WITH, BUT REASON OUT,
FOR CORRUPTION.
IN OTHER WORDS, THERE REALLY WAS
A QUID PRO QUO IN UKRAINE.
IT WAS WITH JOE AND EVEN BRAGGED
ABOUT IT ON CAMERA.
ACCORDING TO JAIL, HE NEVER ONE
TIME NEVER EVER EVER SPOKE WITH
HIS SON ABOUT HIS BUSINESS DEALS
EVER.
JUST NEVER CAME UP.
TAKE A LOOK.
>> MR. PRESIDENT, HOW MANY TIMES
HAVE YOU SPOKEN TO YOUR SON
ABOUT HIS OVERSEAS DEALINGS?
>> I'VE NEVER DISCUSSED WITH MY
SON OR MY BROTHER OR ANYONE ELSE
ANYTHING TO DO WITH THE BUSINESS
IS PERIOD.
WHAT I WILL DO IS THE SAME THING
WE DID IN OUR ADMINISTRATION.
ABSOLUTE LAW BETWEEN PERSONAL
AND PRIVATE AND THE GOVERNMENT.
>> DO YOU STAND BY YOUR
STATEMENT THAT YOU DID NOT
DISCUSS ANY OF YOUR SON'S
BUSINESS DEALS?
>> I STAND BY THAT STATEMENT.
>> Sean: WE ALL NOW KNOW
THAT'S A FLAT OUT LIKE A MOVIE
GOT EVIDENCE TO PROVE IT.
NOT ONLY DID JOE KNOW ABOUT HIS
SON'S BUSINESS PARTNERS, HE
ACTUALLY MET WITH THEM!
HERE IS JOE AND HUNTER, PICTURED
WITH JOE'S FAVORITE KAZAKHSTAN
OLIGARCH, AND HERE IS JOE WITH
HUNTER'S MEXICAN BUSINESS
ASSOCIATES.
WHILE THEN VICE PRESIDENT
JOE BIDEN MET WITH HUNTER'S
PARTNERS, HUNTER WAS PAYING
DADDY'S BILLS.
ACCORDING TO EMAILS AND TEXT
MESSAGES ON THE LAPTOP FROM
HELL, HUNTER ACTED LIKE A BAGMAN
FOR THE ENTIRE SYNDICATE, RAKING
IN CASH, PAYING OFF ALL THE
BILLS.
CLEARLY THIS RAISES MASSIVE
CONCERNS ABOUT WHETHER OR NOT
YOUR PRESIDENT, THE PRESIDENT OF
THE UNITED STATES, JOE BIDEN,
WAS COMPROMISED.
NOW -- OH!
THE MEDIA MOB, WEREN'T THEY
INTERESTED IF THERE WAS ANY
TRUMP-RUSSIA COLLUSION THAT
TURNED OUT TO BE A BIG
CONSPIRACY?
WHY AREN'T THEY INTERESTED IN
THIS?
THOSE WITH TRUMP DERANGEMENT
SYNDROME, THEY DIDN'T CARE.
THEY WERE SO DESPERATE TO BEAT
DONALD TRUMP, THEY DID THEIR
VERY BEST TO COVER ALL OF IT UP.
OCTOBER 2020, SOCIAL MEDIA GIANT
TWITTER, REMEMBER THIS?
THEY LOCKED "THE NEW YORK POST"
OUT OF THEIR OWN ACCOUNT FOR
DARING TO PUBLISH THE VERY TRUE
LAPTOP STORY?
TWITTER USERS, THEY WERE ALSO
BLOCKED FROM SHARING THE REPORT
EVEN IN PRIVATE MESSAGES.
FACEBOOK, THEY CENSOR THE REPORT
AS WELL.
TWO WEEKS BEFORE THE ELECTION,
MORE THAN 50 FORMER U.S. INTEL
OFFICIALS SIGNED A LETTER
CALLING THE LAPTOP STORY
"RUSSIAN DISINFORMATION."
THEY HAD NO REASON TO CALL IT
THAT.
THEY ARE ALL LYING AND
PROTECTING JOE.
MEANWHILE, NPR, THEY ANNOUNCED
THEY WOULDN'T WASTE THEIR TIME
ON THE HUNTER BIDEN REPORT
BECAUSE THERE WASN'T REALLY A
STORY.
IT WAS DONALD TRUMP'S SONS, IT
WOULD BE A STORY.
ONE "NEW YORK TIMES" ARTICLE
REPAIRING TO THE REPORT AS
FARCICAL RUSSIAN DISINFORMATION.
"THE WASHINGTON POST" ALSO
SUGGESTED WITHOUT EVIDENCE THAT
IT WAS PART OF SOME FOREIGN
ELECTION DISINFORMATION SCHEME.
WHERE IS THE PROOF?
WHERE IS THE EVIDENCE?
NONE OF THESE OUTLETS NEVER LIFT
A FINGER OR A TOTAL VERIFY THE
LAPTOP UNTIL NOW.
AND YOUR REPORT IN
"THE WASHINGTON POST" DETAILS
WHAT WE'VE BEEN TELLING YOU NOW
FOR NEARLY TWO YEARS ON THIS
PROGRAM HERE THAT IS ZERO
EXPERIENCE HUNTER BIDEN GOT PAID